let me give you a glimpse into how we will be working with the
with graph data structures. So we said that we have four primitive data
types, right? Yes.
We said we have four primitive data types. And these are these are
these are the ones to which we preferring.
Okay.
now
Let me take you to the slides for a second.
even that list
has different ways to be implemented.
There are different ways to implement a list.
You will get this later on.
but
one thing that python doesn't have internally.
Is a graph data structure and if you remember we said
that a tree is a special type of graph.
Okay, so the examples that we looked at or at
least for the first three there, let's set the tubals. Those are like
array arrays.
whereas dictionaries
Are graph data structures?
Let's say we can Implement a small binary tree.
And let's look at something that this one this is small enough.
In your opinion, how would you implement this?
And with what would you implemented which would which one of
those four primitive data structures?
Would you implement the binary tree?
And once again, what do we
say? A binary tree is there is a graph Theory structure.
With the edges go to only one
element.
excuse me, the only division element only
once
Okay, so unlike a graph where you can have circular.
edges with a tree you have
just it it's only one direction.
There's no circular.
Okay, and it has the effect with a binary
tree a special type of
tree data structure now other trees include beaches
which are implemented which is what how
databases mainly stored data if
you work with
if you've ever wondered how
Data strong, excuse me, databases, especially now great.
Yeah. No SQL databases.
They have a reason why they're fast.
but how do
SQL databases returned it quickly.
It's because they don't actually store list. They actually store data in
the form of a B3.
a B3 is a type of tree that doesn't
just have
two child nodes a binary tree has only two channels right
binaries either left or right left or right?
What is a b-3 can have 1,000 child notes.
Okay, a binary tree will have only two child
nodes.
a beach we can have 1,000 Charles and there they
work especially well for
Databases but we look at what those examples afterwards.
Anyway, the point of
a binary tree is what is to have the search time or if
it's actually better than having. It's the log
event log base 2 event.
because you're having
every subbranch